I love dogs, I’ve always loved dogs.
But there’s always the debate... purebred
or mutt?
It’s a great year to be a dog lover!
Apparently 7 new dog breeds will be shown
at the Westminster dog show!
I don’t know about you, but dog shows…
give me mixed feels.
On a personal level, PUUPPIES, but the science
part of me wants to know, why are there so
many different dog breeds and is that good
for the species?
I mean domesticated dogs might have been around
for 40,000 years and all pretty much looked
like wolves.
But the few hundred dog breeds we know and
love today, have only been around for a couple
of hundred years at the most.
Humans tinkered with dogs, selecting for temperament
or physical traits.
Things like distinguishing markings, the color
of a coat and other physical features like
head and body shape.
A new dog breed has to meet very specific
requirements to qualify as an official breed.
Many organizations like the American Kennel
Club demand proof that every dog used to make
the new breed was a certified purebred.
And in many cases, breeders need to get their
dogs DNA and genotype tested to show a “an
acceptable DNA variation sample for the breed”.
Since 2003, researchers have been able to
see exactly what that genetic pool looks like
thanks to an effort lead by Ewen Kirkness
at The Institute for Genome Research which
sequenced the dog genome.
They also studied the genomes of different
breeds.
And not surprisingly they found that the variation
of genes was greater between dogs of different
breeds than they were within the same breed.
So, a black lab and a golden lab will have
less variation than a black lab and a bulldog.
But what’s interesting is that variation
can be as much as 27.5 percent between dogs
of different breeds, even though essentially,
they are the same species.
Now compare that to humans who only have a
genetic variation of 5.4 percent.
When humans mess with dog’s shape and coloring,
they are actually messing with their genes.
Like size is pretty much controlled by one
gene on chromosome 15 called insulin-like
growth factor-1.
(IGF1), which is known to influence body size
in humans and mice.
But it’s mutation can be found in a lot
of unrelated smaller breeds, suggesting it’s
ancient.
Even though it’s a few thousand years old,
it’s a change that still happened faster
than it would happen naturally.
So all the tinkering humans do to dog breeds,
dramatically changes dog’s genes faster
than nature would.
With all that genetic tinkering, some weird
stuff happened.
Not surprisingly, breeding for aesthetic purposes
has some.. unintended consequences.
Like pug encephalitis and hip problems in
German shepherds.
And one study in PLOS One found that changing
a dog’s face, changes their brains too.
In dogs with short snouts, their brains have
rotated 15 degrees backwards and the smell
region in their brain is in a completely different
place from other breeds.
And these kinds of brain changes are common
in other dogs too.
Another study also published in PLOS One found
that Chiari malformation in dogs actually
changes their skull and brain formation.
It’s a physical defect that occurs in a
lot of small dogs that are bred to look more
“doll like”.
It basically makes the forehead bigger but
also changes the brain shape.
It can cause chronic conditions like headaches,
problems with walking or even paralysis.
One of the lead authors of the study Clare
Rusbridge, described the condition “as trying
to fit a big foot into a small shoe.”
Which just sounds utterly painful.
The physical defects caused by inbreeding
is a huge problem and it’s one of the reasons
why some breeders are calling for stricter
regulations and practices.
Thankfully there are responsible breeders
who are using genetic science to ensure they
are breeding to maintain genetic diversity,
resulting in new breeds that are both healthy
and happy.
While we’ve bred dogs to be stronger, smaller,
or even more docile, they all come from a
wolf like ancestor thousands of years ago.
At some point, dogs evolved to become man’s
best friend?
When did this take place?
So what’s your fav dog breed?
Mine’s a mutt.